it is true that mentioned behead like
how he can't really defend himself but
he can also leave the situation a lot
easier than a woman who is being abused
because they're typically smaller than
their partners and physically not the
same like kind of match okay guys you'll
notice this trend with modern women and
feminists whenever you try to hold a
woman accountable they move the goal
post and say well but he could leave
imagine imagine let's let's flip this
flip the script right if she she's
getting hit girls getting hit well she
could have laughed she could leave
is that
is that is that right is that how we
should talk